à cause des travaux constants qui furent nécessaires
pour construire la voie rapide qui traverse le Bronx,
à un pâté de maison de chez eux.
J'estime que ces décisions politiques
ont engendré la criminalité.
(Applaudissements)
Mais résilients comme nous le sommes,
face à cette oppression systématique,
la culture hip-hop a germé des ruines et des cendres tel un phénix.
Le hip-hop est aujourd'hui une industrie milliardaire,
mais cet argent ne revient pas dans le Bronx,
ni dans des quartiers similaires.
Revenons à 1986.
Je suis né au cœur de la crise du SIDA,
de l'épidémie de crack
et de la guerre contre les drogues.
La seule chose qui soit issue des Reaganomics, c'est les « ghettonomics » :
la souffrance, la prison et la pauvreté.
J'ai été élevé par des femmes noires, géniales, magnifiques et accomplies.
Et pourtant, mon daron n'a jamais été là,
et je n'ai pas su résister à l'appel de la rue.
Comme le disait Biggie,
soit tu fourguais du crack, soit tu étais un Dieu au basket.
Ne vous méprenez pas, je mouillais le maillot.
(Rires)
Je jouais super bien.
(Applaudissements)
Mais quand j'ai eu 15 ans, j'ai commencé à vendre de l'herbe,
je n'ai pas fini le lycée,
le rectorat de New York m'a exclu de tous les lycées,
mais j'ai eu mon diplôme de vendeur de cocaïne quand j'avais 18 ans.
Je me débrouillais bien.
Jusqu'à ce que je sois coffré, envoyé au tribunal, à 20 ans.
Je risquais 10 ans.
J'ai payé la caution, je me suis inscrit au Fashion Institute of Technology,
j'ai utilisé les compétences acquises dans la rue,
pour lancer ma propre marque de mode.
Mon avocat a senti mon ambition,
et a suggéré au juge de m'infliger une peine suspensive.
Pour une fois, une suspension était une bonne chose.
(Rires)
En deux ans, et après de nombreux passages au tribunal,
j'ai été relaxé.
Mes deux frères avaient fait de la prison,
donc m'échapper des griffes du complexe industriel carcéral
ne me paraissait pas réaliste.
En ce moment, un de mes frères risque 20 ans de prison.
Ma mère a bataillé pour m'emmener manger dehors,
s'assurer que nous visitions des musées
et voyagions à l'étranger ;
elle voulait me confronter autant que possible à la culture.
Je me rappelle comment, enfant,
je montais sur la table et je commandais pour tout le monde.
Rompre le pain m'a toujours permis de briser le moule
et de me connecter aux autres.
Mon pote Les et moi,
on a grandi dans la même cité du Bronx,
deux frères de la rue.
Il est devenu chef.
On avait toujours parlé de faire quelque chose dans la gastronomie
au profit des gens du quartier.
Les vient de remporter l'émission de télé « Chopped ».
Notre pote Malcolm était sur le point d'ouvrir une pâtisserie chez Noma,
oui, un des meilleurs restaurants de Copenhague, vous connaissez la pub.
Mon copain P avait juste terminé sa formation en Italie,
à Milan pour être précis.
On a décidé que le monde avait besoin que le Bronx s'approprie tout ça,
on s'est donc tous associés et on a monté Ghetto Gastro.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai bien conscience que notre nom rend plein de gens mal à l'aise,
mais pour nous, le ghetto, c'est notre maison.
De la même manière que quelqu'un de Bombay ou de Nairobi
utilise le mot « bidonville »,
cela nous place sur la carte
et accuse le système de négligence qui a créé ces conditions.
(Applaudissements)
Qu'est-ce que Ghetto Gastro ?
En fin de compte, c'est un mouvement et une philosophie.
Pour nous, on fait de la gastrodiplomatie.
On se sert de la nourriture et du goût
pour ouvrir les frontières et connecter les cultures.
L'année dernière à Tokyo,
on a proposé des pâtés caribéens,
du « jerk » de bœuf wagyu,
du kombu shio.
On a mélangé les classiques du Bronx avec les éléments japonais.
Et pour Kwanzaa,
on a rendu hommage aux Portoricains,
et on a servi des coquitos grillés au cognac et à la noix de coco. Dimelo !
(Rires)
Voici notre gaufre Black Power,
avec du sirop à la feuille d'or.
Attention à ne pas en verser à côté.
(Rires)
Voici le Velato végétarien à 36 degrés Brix.
« Strawberry fields », vous connaissez la suite.
De la pastèque compressée,
des pousses de basilic,
un peu de fraises par-dessus.
Retour à la Brasserie du Bronx,
on n'a pas dû leur faire plaisir avec le caviar sur du pain de maïs.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
On pratique aussi la diplomatie du bandana Du-Rag.
(Rires)
On ne dit pas qui on est quand on travaille.
A cause de notre look,
on nous prend souvent pour des rappeurs ou des athlètes.
C'est arrivé ici l'année dernière à TED.
Un type s'est approché de moi
pour demander quand j'allais me produire.
T'en penses quoi aujourd'hui ?
(Applaudissements)
Donc vous voyez,
on a apporté le Bronx au monde
et maintenant on essaie d'apporter le monde au Bronx.
On vient juste d'ouvrir,
une cuisine inventive
où on invente, où on crée nos produits,
notre contenu –
(Musique)
et où on organise des événements.
Le but est de monter une affaire rentable,
mais aussi créative, dans notre ghetto.
On travaille aussi avec le chef à la renommée mondiale,
Massimo Bottura,
sur un « refettorio » dans le Bronx.
Un refettorio est une soupe populaire design et un centre social.
Vous voyez le genre.
(Applaudissements)
Il y a peu, l'émoi causé par le meurtre
du rappeur et entrepreneur Nipsey Hussle
est largement dû au fait qu'il a décidé de rester et d'évoluer ici,
plutôt que de quitter le ghetto.
Après sa mort, certains ont pu penser que sa décision était stupide,
mais c'est celle que je prends tous les jours :
vivre dans le Bronx,
créer dans le Bronx,
investir dans le Bronx.
(Applaudissements)
A Ghetto Gastro, on n'a pas honte du mot « ghetto »
et on n'a pas honte du ghetto.
Parce que finalement,
Ghetto Gastro va vous montrer ce que nous savons déjà :
le ghetto,
c'est la classe.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.